[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
chris mannix sports illustrated nba
senior writer
joining us on the program annex how are
you today
a little stomach churning dan mayo is
disgusting it is
like i i wouldn't like i mean i'm a big
tuna fish eater but i'll eat it dry
at all times before i put mayo in that
mix same thing with
with lobster rolls i mean hell no with
man
no it's hell men's well either way gross
all right well thanks for coming on
chris that's all i wanted to talk to you
about
uh i thought draymond green accomplished
what draymond green wanted to do and
that is he loves to troll people and
you know him and tony allen going back
and forth as to who's the greatest
defender
um those guys aren't even in you know in
the conversation
but draymond is a really good player
um i i don't know where you would put
him as great defender of all time
but uh i might as well i just spent you
know 10 minutes talking about it so i
might as well let you address it
yeah i mean he you're right he
accomplished exactly what he
set out to accomplish which was to set
social media ablaze
with the conversation uh tony allen gets
roped into it but
i think the only way you could have this
discussion is to talk about generations
right i mean
maybe draymond green is the best
defender of this generation he is
certainly the most
versatile defender better than corey
leonard
uh i mean i liked how draymond could
guard basically two to five
for a period of time there was like a
three-year stretch he could do that
um so it's it's it's right there but
then you go back and you talk about
mutumbo and gary payton and you go back
even further and it's the
the bill russell discussion which i
think is where it stops
um so i i you know look draymond
is one of certainly but it's hard to
point him at the top uh yeah i'm with
you on that i i
russell akeem elijah on tim duncan great
defender
pip and jordan you know there's so many
great great players
uh you know but as seton pointed out you
could use you could hand check
back then you know draymond is playing
in an era where you can't really use
your hands on anybody but
i would probably look at kawhi's i
remember that i remember back in the day
when i was working for the celtics in
the 90s and i ran into russell
you know one day the rare appearance he
had in boston
this subject kind of came up where you
know
was he being discounted as a great
defender because the era he played in
russell always said he said
you know shaq was the guy he'd have a
problem with because of shaq's just raw
size
he's like anybody else i could handle i
i i could defend anybody else in this
league from whatever generation you're
talking about that's how confident
russell was
in his own defensive abilities all right
let's dive into it i know you're trying
to make a case because
i guess there's 58 guys who are up for
the mvp in the nba
so um the floor is yours your latest mvp
candidate
is i mean your hatred for all things
french
notwithstanding um rudy gobert is
is certainly making i think a strong
case to be in consideration
for mvp and i put this on twitter the
other night of course you get ratioed
left and right by people that are saying
he's not even
the best center in his division whose
nikola jokic is
certainly there but i i just get i'm
tired of like everybody looking at raw
numbers i mean rudy gobert
is so much better than his numbers i
mean i
i tweeted that after the chicago game
where rudy went for what 20
you know almost a triple-double with
blocks in there and was just this
presence every minute he was on the
floor i mean he is
with all due respect to ben simmons the
defensive player of the year and i think
it's a pretty uh
wide gap and offensively you know you
and i had this debate last time but he
springs everybody on that jazz team
with his screen setting so as far as
impactful players
on both ends of the floor rudy gobert is
right up there with the most
impactful on both ends i'm not i'm not
going to vote for him i don't think for
mvp
because i think there are better players
in that mix but can he finish top five
i think that's possible i don't think
you can go to bat for him
on a social platform and then say you're
not voting for him
if the season ended today
where does rudy gobert end up on your
ballot
somewhere between five and seven right
now oh my god right now
why why am i having you on to talk about
this
because i i didn't say he was the mvp i
said he should be in the mix for mbps
how many guys are in the mix for mvp
chris can we stop
this it feels like it it grows
exponentially
now there's 15 guys that you can say
that that's because dan
the the calculus keeps changing right
like
joelle embiid was the front runner for
an extended period of time
and then he goes down with an injury
lebron james looked like the front
runner
but he could be out until mid april
which changes the dynamic
if rudy gobert stays healthy and plays
the rest of the season
you can certainly make an argument that
he should be considered mvp
i actually think and i'm going to try to
write this next week but i think there's
an even stronger argument
that you should give it to giannis for a
third year in a row look at what he's
doing right now
he's not good he's out with a minor knee
injury but i mean
you know the numbers are largely the
same from last year if that bucks team
finishes with the best record in the
east
which is certainly possible i i don't
want to hear about voter fatigue with
giannis he might deserve a third mvp
well no this just has to do with and it
shouldn't
what they have not done in the
postseason if the bucks won the title
last year and giannis was still it was
having this season
then i think the voters would look at
him differently you don't even hear
giannis's
name with the top mvp candidates we're
we're
going out of our way that's bad on the
voters though dan
like that's bad on the voters who again
i think it's voter fatigue who are just
looking like i don't want to vote for
giannis again
there's only a handful of guys that have
won three mvps in a row
giannis doesn't deserve to be in that
rarefied air no it's all in a vacuum
it's based on the regular season and i
think you're going to have
a hard time saying that there are better
players than giannis having a regular
season
trade deadline well let me start with
the lakers here with
with a.d and lebron still out what are
that what's the risk
that they're running here and can they
do will they do anything at the trade
deadline
i don't believe they do anything at the
trade deadline
because i mean they don't have a lot of
assets to deal anyway they've shipped
out many of their draft picks in
previous trades and
the one guy teams want horton tucker is
the player the lakers
are not going to deal right now right
now it's just kind of
bite down and see if you can get one win
out of every four
and keep yourself in the mix until
lebron
and a.d come back i watched that at
least the first three quarters of that
pelicans game last night i turned it off
and it was like 102 to 70 something at
the end of the third quarter
it's just it's gonna get ugly in los
angeles over these next few weeks and
they've just got to hope
that they stay inside that top eight in
time for lebron
and a.d to come back and look as long as
those two are back in mid april
that gives them you know three four
weeks to climb back up in the standings
so i'm not
yet concerned about them missing the
playoffs but it is going to be
a really ugly next few weeks in la
because they don't do
anything well you know they're i think
they're still the number one defensive
team in the league statistically but
they're not a good defense and
offensively they're just mixing and
matching
guys out there so i i think it's going
to be a tough tough stretch for the
lakers
and then it comes to marquee names uh
aaron gordon
kyle lowry feels like that's about it or
both
both going to be moved well it's pretty
clear
at this point that aaron gordon is going
to be moved
i think boston and denver are two of the
leading contenders right now
for gordon and it's just going to come
down to
you know it really comes down to what
orlando is going to accept right now
there's a gap
in what teams are offering and what the
magic want to get back but i think that
gap is going to be closed before
thursday afternoon so i think gordon
moves
evan fournier his teammate i think is
going to move with him uh when that deal
ultimately happens oladipo i think the
next interest in oladipo
is vastly overstated i don't think that
tom thibodeau's in love
with oladipo there nor do i think he
fits their timeline uh but i do think
oladipo gets auctioned off at some point
somewhere
lowry is interesting i think miami
continues to be the front-runner there
because they'll part
with duncan robinson and robinson is
probably the best player
that the raptors can get back in that
mix the most interesting player though
dan
is john collins um you know john collins
is an excellent player and the hawks
have made him available but they're
asking prices high
and i'm not expecting that asking price
uh to go down so
john collins is the one that i'm not
sure is going to move i'm very sure that
gordon
and oladipo are likely to move lowry i
think is likely to move along with
norman powell
uh but uh john collins is the one player
that
i you still are not sure if he's gonna
move i like what the suns are doing
and they're doing it quietly i don't
know if they're just a a regular season
team they picked up from the bubble
where they went undefeated in this
season so
uh handicapped the phoenix sun's bigger
picture here
look they've got a chance to be a
conference finalist at least
in that conference because chris paul
has made them a tougher playoff
team uh but beyond paul you know i i
really like what deandre ayton has done
this year i mean ayton
is forever going to be compared to luka
doncic and will never put up the kind of
numbers or probably win the kind of
awards
that janchak has done but what ayton has
done this year
has accepted that defense is his primary
responsibility and this son's team i
believe
is still ranked inside the top 10
defensively and that's largely because
deandre ayton has made a commitment
to that end he's still putting up
numbers when he can on the offensive end
and chris paul
you know if you watch the game last
night goes out of his way to make sure
ayden gets some you know easy buckets
around the rim
but he is locked in on that end of the
floor and
if they're able to be top 10 defensively
they're going to give any team in that
conference a real problem
great to talk to you as always chris uh
have fun and uh
thanks for joining us you got it dan
that's uh chris mannix sports
illustrated nba senior writer